this has been a mess in the republican
party right now representative liz
cheney says she will do
everything she can to make sure that
trump never again
gets anywhere near the oval office the
business insider story
she's from wyoming on wednesday said
she's determined to prevent former
president donald trump from returning to
the white house i will do everything i
can
to ensure the former president never
gets it anywhere near the oval office we
have seen the danger that he continues
to provoke with his language
we have seen his lack of commitment and
dedication to the constitution cheney
told reporters on capitol hill
the comments came after cheney was
ousted as chair of the house republican
conference in a voice vote on wednesday
morning gop members voted to remove
cheney from the top
leadership post over repeated criticism
of the former president and opposition
to his lies about the 2020 presidential
election she was also
one of the top one of the 10 house
republicans who voted to impeach trump
over his role
in the capital insurrection on january 6
thoughts my thought is she's a liar
and and i'm glad she's gone and i say
that from personal experience i ran the
investigative side of the president's
rebuttal on the election
i saw the three thousand affidavits from
people
that witnessed voter fraud election
fraud in six different states
she was never briefed she was never
interviewed
she never called us she never questioned
us
she hasn't seen one bit of evidence out
of the outrageous evidence of voter and
election fraud
yet make statements like that and for
that she shouldn't be in congress
i don't i don't know liz cheney
personally like you don't know or not
not you know personally but um and i've
said this before
people are like oh the democratic party
is falling apart the socialists are
taking over but
from my opinion they'll at least
coalesce during an election and come
together
in my opinion the the party that is
being fractured
is republicans you have what does it say
100 republicans
including former governors and lawmakers
are threatening to form a third party
these are people that were lifelong
republicans
the bushes of the world the cheneys of
the world the george wills of the world
we saw
you know how the um the lincoln project
took over the collapse though
it didn't end well let's just correct
but they did
they did bring down trump they did from
the democrats used them to bring him
down and then afterwards they crash and
burn because they're no longer needed
they're the useful idiots some call them
well they knew what they were doing
some of them called them the useful
idiots they were useful when needed the
moment everything was accomplished now
it's no longer fair enough but the point
is that i'm trying to make is if there
is some the bigger division is
definitely in the republican party than
it is the democratic party
right now we'll see what happens i don't
agree with you i'm actually on you on
your side with this because this
is so you have to realize i if you
if you knew how powerful dick cheney was
he he literally ran the show no no the
guy is a strategy
he's one of the scariest guys in
politics the guy was a strategist the
guy was a
he was feared by his peers he's so
powerful he could shoot his buddy in the
face and not pay a price
the you can say that because that's
actually a factual statement yeah
so so can you imagine his daughter she's
got those genes
yeah the genetics of a fighter the
genetics of defending and cheney was
whose vp
cheney was bushes okay in the bushes and
trumps how's the relationship did it go
to dinner to get that market
and trump's not good zone not so good so
because they're closer with obama's at
this point of course so the point is you
have to know where the loyalty lies
right where the loyalty lies it's like
cindy mccain now here's a question megan
mccann here's a question for you here's
a crazy question for you here's a crazy
question for you it's getting crazy
uh sam am i above my appointment uh what
uh 1102.
okay so here's a question crazy question
for you here's a crazy question for you
republican party say there's a split we
have a third party i know we have like
a few other third parties whatever
independent libertarian green all that
but i'm talking about like a legitimate
20
25 party right
which party is more like ronald reagan
the liz cheney bush
you know party the the the the what do
you call it the conservative republicans
the lincoln project do you think they're
more like
reagan or do you think trump's mega
party is more like reagan
who's more more like like reaganomics
like reagan the way he ran america
who's more like reagan trumps you think
so 100 what do you think
i'm taking the opposite so let me if you
listen to your typical if you're
listening
if you're listening to this yeah thumbs
up if you think
the the the trump is more like reagan
versus
the chinese the bushes of the world are
like reagan thumbs up it's more trump
like reagan thumbs down if no
it's bush cheney or more like reagan i
actually want to hear your thoughts when
you're saying this so tell me why you
say ray
uh trump's camp mega is more like reagan
because he believes in much of the same
stuff reagan did
you know smaller government you know the
the bush
can republican party is all about the
swamp
it's all about the swamp it's all the
the connections the
the long time connections of washington
d.c
and look i i got to be honest i followed
this stuff for years
i never got involved as much as i did in
the aftermath
of the election and there were people on
the bush side of the house the
republican side of the house
basically saying leave leave the
leave the election alone don't talk
about it don't go public
don't cooperate with them don't talk to
the president's legal team
why why not what are you hiding
or what are you trying to prevent from
happening the bottom line is
there was overwhelming evidence of voter
and election fraud
i saw it i collected the affidavits we
interviewed
hundreds of people i got it but
why wouldn't you want that to come out
why is it why is it
not okay to talk about it they censored
the president they
censored the president they've censored
anybody that goes on social media and
tries to talk about it
for the people that were there that saw
what i saw
this is outrageous and i don't give a
[ __ ] if it's republican and democrat
i don't care the bottom line is every
vote should count
and every vote should be ill legal a
legal vote
when you have 350 000
ballots that are cast between 1 a.m
and 5 a.m in pittsburgh and there's no
republican observers
okay that's illegal it's illegal it's a
[ __ ] crime
when you have a hundred and fifty
thousand cast in philadelphia
between one and five am that's a crime
why hasn't it been investigated how can
liz cheney stand up and say
it's all a lie what do you say to those
who say uh bernard this has already been
addressed it went to court
even uh georgia you know the governor
came out and he didn't do anything even
you know you can go to
here's what you say about the court
issue the court issue
and i'll i'll finish with this one
statement the court issues in
in almost every case there was no state
they didn't find that the
petitioner had standing or they said
it's a state issue
and you know what they're right here's
the bottom line for the people that were
there
the democrats stole the election they
infused ballots
they [ __ ] with the machines they had
dead people voting
in the thousands they stole the election
but that
is not why donald trump is not the
president today
donald trump is not the president today
because the state legislators
in the six swing states certified false
votes
and they knew it and they knew it they
certified
their election numbers in those states
just to get it over
why because they're a part of that bush
entourage that bush party they hated
trump they didn't like what he stood for
and they are the reason he's not in the
white house today
so you're saying it's the actual
republicans who are running 100
so not even the democrats you're saying
is it the democrats or the republicans
the democrats stole the election but if
the republicans did their job if the
state legislators did their job
and did not certify those votes until
there was a real investigation you have
arizona right now
right now today they're still in court
messing with the audit in arizona you
have the same thing going on in michigan
in antrim county
where they found the turnover of trump
votes to biden
they found them in the machines that
stuff is still going on
the certifications should have never
been done let me ask you
and in the the great words of uh big
lebowski
it's kind of like your opinion man how
accurate do you think no no
meaning like are you 1000 confidence is
exactly what happened or it's like look
i kind of think this is what happened
i am a thousand percent confident you
know why because i have the affidavits
i have the legal affidavits they're
sworn under the penalty of perjury
there's thousands of them thousands what
do you [ __ ] ignore these people
that were there what about you who do
you blame for all this because you sound
like you're blaming republicans
i am blaming republicans oh my god i
am but by the way say there's a third
party let's break those two apart
say there's a third party okay so so now
no if there's a third party by a
landslide who wins
democrats by a landslide not even close
or
or does because because it seems like
the fear is so high that they're
thinking trump's going to run 2024.
do you think he is 20 24 i don't know
what's your best 80
chance 60 50 80 80 very high
yeah 80 runs okay listen if so many
people
are doing everything in their power to
prevent it from happening
they're thinking very high likelihood
he's going to be running and they're
scared that's all i can say to you
and i don't know okay no no no bro if
you're saying stuff like this this is
only stemmed from fear what if what if
this takes place petrified
yeah there you don't think this is
coming from conviction
and moral authority i do think it is but
the only reason you're putting so much
energy into it is because you also
believe
odds are this guy's gonna run we cannot
have this guy wrong because if he runs
what's he gonna do
what's he gonna expose what's he gonna
show what's he going to revert back to
what's going to be taking place what's
going to be the next swamp we're going
to lose our deals i don't know so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]